i was there
for one of the greatest norm moments in
comedy history i think he he was kinked
he was kicked out of nebraska
that sounds realistic um and i you can
maybe look it up later versus norma
mcdonald was kicked out of the state by
the governor
and he went on he went on
letterman to talk about it
uh and i want to say it was like 1996
because i just finished my first year
snl was 95 so it was the summer of 96
and i remember going on tour
there you go you saw it go down yeah
kicked out of iowa that's me talking
about it okay uh but anyway should we
look on a video or should we no no don't
look at that i want to see the real
there has to be a headline how nor
mcdonald got kicked out of iowa yes okay
gazette there you go
okay
all right
so
many were disgusted somewhere delighted
so he's supposed to know you understand
something okay
he
his first time me touring with a star
okay we go to the airport and people
like oh my god you're norm mcdonald wow
this is everywhere we went oh my god
you're norm mcdonald we show up at the
university he's like yeah i gotta go
golfing with the [ __ ] governor they
made me a [ __ ] golf
[ __ ] governor yeah what did that game
were
he's with a governor this is huge who
gets to say that
so i'm i'm it's me daryl hammond and him
and you you all both you guys went we're
all we're on the gig okay okay we're
going out he's telling us yes and so uh
we get to the gig
and
is
packed
and they go now listen there's kids here
and there's students and alum and the
dean
and all these people here so that's the
worst they're like yeah clean i get it
no worries i go we're in sunny lake i
guess that's why we got you guys because
you're used to live tv pull up so daryl
goes up first does his 20 minutes does
impressions
does his comedy
hilarious
um
i go up
do my 20 feel great crush it
norm goes up i'm not even exaggerating
the first thing he says he goes out he
gets
ah
look it's like i'm preparing i'm like
this is gonna launch my crew are you
kidding me this is gonna be huge i'm
gonna be off he and [ __ ] where the
[ __ ] at me
the first person even curse all right oh
[ __ ] he cursed he goes
so
if you're gay
would you rather be the ass guy
or the dick guy
this is what he starts off with
so
i go i go daryl you got to come see this
and he's going and he won't stop he's
there because he'll being depressed
about he's going off people are grabbing
their kids
running up the aisle they're i mean i
never saw a place clear out like a fire
alarm was going off but the college
students were staying and they were
howling with laughter and he
one thing and then in the middle after
about 15 minutes he
jesus christ what are you going to do
[ __ ] airplane jokes
he went [ __ ] 7-11 joe said jesus
christ [ __ ] out of here
so the next day
in the paper
usa today or the cassette like norma
mcdonald's out wow governor wants him
out of this stay
get out of my state
this is stupid but on my phone this guy
you'll laugh at this maybe a lot of
people get these pictures or tattoos you
know like of me as joe dirt you know
they send you a lot of you get a lot of
tattoos of stuff like things you say or
photos or whatever they send me one's a
farley or whatever so this this guy says
we wanna he's got norm of all
morons on his hand nor mcdonald so i
text norm i go i just send it to him i
go hey you have fans and then i put
princess fan
oh
all we know is for sure this one guy
and then um and then of course like
days later david hello it's me norm
how are you
have you ever texted with norm it's no i
haven't no times a thousand he just goes
he waits days and then at three in the
morning hello
i go norm what are you doing are you
answering me from four days ago is that
what you're doing dave it's norm
you like money
yes norm i like money why would you like
to have more money than all your wildest
dreams
yes i would
and then an hour later would you like to
walk into a dealership and point to a
car and then just buy it i go of course
i how and then three hours later bet the
over in the blackhawks game
first period or something i go oh okay
two man that game was six days ago
and so norm was headlining
and i think there were three or four
comics who were doing
five maybe eight minute sets and at that
time it was all the material they had
you know they were new comics
okay i've polished off i said i got
these jokes and now i'm going to go out
with this guy he's a great headliner and
we're going to do this big corporate gig
and so at the gig as they were starting
norm off the top said i'm just going to
go out there and kind of warm up the
crowd you know do a little teaser and
then you guys do set someone coming so
norm went up
and apparently
did everyone else's material
did all the is this sorry yeah
jokes
and the what i loved is that i was told
to hear like first of all we those are
the only jokes we had but the worst
thing about it is norm's jokes were
better like our jokes were he had he had
so like he had three hours and he was
going to do an hour on this show
so he he was only doing it to [ __ ] with
them oh and he said but we were just
mortified because it's like we it's not
like we have a lesser five minutes right
he's like that was everything
he went and when he came off he was just
it was just a joke and he's like rat
that's your turn yeah your turn oh my
gosh i think they just went up and
flopped and like tried to do crowd work
and
i just
i liked the motivelessness of it yeah
what were you thinking i must have been
crazy that's also only a joke for the
other comics
yeah they saw they saw like a pretty
okay opening and then what the hell
happened in the middle and then the guy
that closed was came back and he was
still not killed yeah
that's i just love that yeah oh my god
well that's mortifying
and then he also didn't get any npr swag
it happens at all at all
that does make me feel better
[Music]
one time i had to open up for him and
this is at a casino or doing like a
casino gig
in
shawnee oklahoma
and
cherokee creek casino i think and it
could have
i don't know this cool lady that i think
maybe try to make love to somebody but
she also helped us get the gig and um
norm was [ __ ] up i think that when he
went on he went on after me like i don't
think he i don't even think for the
first seven minutes i don't even think
he said anything right but the crazy
part was
the next day um
we were at there was like we had to play
cards too the next day you'd like be
there for the weekend you know so we'd
go to the card tables and
norma's like well there's a lot of
a lot of good [ __ ] in here
and i don't know him really well so i'm
thinking i'm looking around this room
bro there is zero attractive women right
they're zero attractive men okay so it's
not even if you wanted something it's a
because there's nothing yeah it's a
casino and it's a it's a gambling game
it's poker yeah five card poker you know
so and i'm just thinking well i guess i
just agree with him you know he's
getting older and you know maybe he has
a different perception of what's
attractive
i'm like yeah man they're sure he goes
[ __ ] no there isn't like he had played
me you know like
he's like this is the ugliest batch of
people i've ever seen
you know what's funny is that that
reminds me i was just thinking about
this the other day norm
was on my late night show and always an
amazing uh guest and some of my favorite
moments and he's in the makeup room
getting made up and you know the band's
playing we're about i'm about to go out
and start the show
but i go in just to say hey
to norman what i want to do is make sure
i like to get in sync with people a
little beforehand just make sure that
you know we're both yeah on the same
page got a good groove going so i go in
the band's plan and norm's always great
like hey norm good to see you he's like
ah
hey yeah yeah can you back out of the
way i'm trying to see that that
television set can you back back up
there conan and tv the tv's on and so i
i sort of back out of the way and i
realize he's watching some college
basketball game and he's watching it
it's towards the end of the game and all
this and i go like okay well anyway good
luck guys can you be quiet yeah quiet
and then someone scores a basket and he
goes and it's the game's over and he
goes like ah [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] and i'm like what anyone i just
lost just lost a lot of money
my whole dirty work yeah guys
everything i made on on dirty work is
gone
and and i just went oh and he went oh
i'm in a terrible mood and i went okay
and then someone with a headset
said conan it's time to go on and i went
i'll see you out there and he's like
you
you came in and jinxed me you jinxed me
there's no one better to talk to about
show business than norm because he's
brutally honest about it like i'll try
to tell the story quick okay when norm
had his last sitcom on fox right uh he
invited me to go the upfronts with you
know that big thing where they
introduced the shows to the advertisers
so the head of fox's guy sandy grushow
right out of beverly hills eye like
permanent tan permanent fake smile on
his face right the head of fox goes up
to norm and it's norm and jason bateman
whose show had premiered and all these
fox people goes up to norm and says
right in front of me and a bunch of
people goes norm i want to let you know
that your show is the highest tested
show
we've had in fox history
and norm goes wow man thanks that's
unbelievable wow and then and then
groucho leaves and goes to talk to jason
bateman so this other executive of fox
this woman tracy something comes over
and goes where's sandy he was just here
norm goes he's over there telling
bateman that his show is the highest
tested show in the history of five
it's another another great
jim will appreciate that they do a big
rolling stone article about the kids ah
that was a great one man
they do a big rolling stone article
about the character i got it
right yeah and uh so why is everybody
kissing each other's ass so they asked
norm about chris katan
and it's after pages of i've never seen
someone do better character work
norm's quote is he seems gay to me
i've never met a guy who said he wasn't
gay who seems so gay
but
i guess he says he's not gay so whatever